[Music]
foreign
corruption like yours must be eradicated
no
master
from 1978 with the one-time airing of
the Star Wars holiday special to the
early 21st century the galaxy far far
away's relationship to TV was fraught
with difficulty a handful of live-action
TV movies an animated series in the
1980s proved that the resources did not
yet exist to produce the look and feel
of Star Wars in a weekly format although
the Ewoks cartoon did get pretty close
by surviving for two whole Seasons Flash
Forward to 2003 and the gendi tarkovsky
produced Star Wars the Clone Wars
offered a way to dramatize Star Wars
stories on television in a compelling
and cost-effective way then the
subsequent 3D animated Clone Wars series
in 2008 started a tradition of Star Wars
television which continues today with
animated shows like Star Wars the bad
batch and the live-action success of the
Mandalorian the latter becoming a
gateway to an ever-evolving story
tangential to the Skywalker Saga but
just as epic it's okay
you okay
[Music]
much of that story can be attributed to
2008's clone wars supervising director
Dave filoni who went on to create or
co-create most of the extant Star Wars
television of course the quality and
appreciation of each show varies
especially with the book of Boba Fett
and Obi-Wan Kenobi series opening up new
possibilities in the Star Wars Galaxy so
it's safe to say the Force is with
television now as we count down the best
Star Wars TV shows all ranked by Tomato
Meter
[Music]
foreign
number 10 the book of Boba Fett on the
Sands of Tatooine Bounty Hunter Boba
Fett and mercenary fanex Shand navigate
the Galaxy's underworld and fight for
Jabba the Hutt's old territory starring
tomorrow Morrison Ming Na Wen Pedro
Pascal and created by John Favreau and
Dave filoni critics say the book of Boba
Fett could never match the adventures
that existed in fans imaginations for
decades but it earns its commission with
spectacular set pieces and tomorrow
Morrison's commanding presence clear out
take your hoodlum gang with you
I've known you a long time
one thing I can't figure
what's your angle
it's my city
these are my people
I will not abandon them
like the tuscans
don't toy with me I'm not a little boy
any longer
and you are an old man
I'm still faster than you
it may be
but I have armor
armor let's find out
how's about the time you shed off to
your back to tank
my city
you gave her the shot
you tried to go straight
but you've got your father's blood
pumping through your veins
you're a killer
number nine Obi-Wan Kenobi
ends with the consequences of his
greatest defeat the downfall in
Corruption of his one-time friend and
Apprentice Anakin Skywalker who turned
to the dark side as the evil Sith Lord
Darth Vader starring Ewan McGregor
Hayden Christensen Moses Ingram and
created by Joby Harold critics say this
won't be the Obi-Wan Kenobi some viewers
are looking for but you and McGregor's
Soulful performance and some refreshing
twists make this a satisfying if
circuitous addition to the Star Wars
saga
[Music]
foreign
number eight Star Wars the bad batch
members of a unique Squad of clones find
their way in a changing galaxy in the
aftermath of the Clone War starring D
Bradley Baker Ming Na Wen Stephen
Stanton and created by Dave filoni
critics say the bad batch is beautifully
animated adventure maybe too lore heavy
for casual viewers but fans will enjoy
diving deeper into this dastardly cast
of characters
[Music]
I've heard mixed things about these guys
they have a 100 success rate
it's not that they win it's how they win
that worries me
coming in on a platform TT 397.
[Applause]
so why haven't I heard of this squad
experimental unit clone Force 99 the
defective clones with the desirable
mutations 99 eh nice touch they call
themselves the bad batch
[Music]
foreign
has arrived
number Seven Star Wars resistance
young New Republic pilot kazuta ziono is
recruited by resistance Commander Poe
Dameron for a secret mission on Colossus
an aircraft refueling station on the
ocean planet of Castle in a
misunderstanding causes Kaz to
participate in a dangerous race to prove
himself Kaz struggles to maintain his
cover as a mechanic and spy as he tries
to adjust to this new normal kaz's work
as a spy takes him across the known
Galaxy on adventures with Poe Dameron
and their droids bb-8 and cb23 as they
seek to bring down the first order
starring Christopher Sean Susie McGrath
Scott Lawrence and created by Dave
filoni critics say Star Wars resistance
to streamline stories sets the stage for
exciting adventures and seems poised to
explore canvas stocked with immediately
relatable characters and plenty of
potential
have you ever met anyone from the first
order niku I've seen a stormtrooper
before but I mean
what do they look like under those
helmets well luckily I have never seen a
stormtrooper but I would not want to
look under their helmets can you hand me
the sub Loop spanner please
I mean I'm not saying that guy is first
order but he does look pretty shady
I was hoping that you could hand me the
sub Loop spanner this time because I
asked for the sub Loop spanner and not
this non-sub Loop spanner that you just
handed me sorry sorry my fault my mind
was inspired I meant fine
getting the ship flying
professionals you say you're in the best
of hands sir they just need another hour
or so look I need to get off this
station soon I'm in a hurry we'll have
you out of here in no time
good my test was a success
the feedback system's working great
ah the feedback system maybe you'll be
more comfortable waiting over here
ah my mind I have some business to take
care of I'll be back
number six and or Rebel Spy Cassian
andor's formative years of the Rebellion
starring Diego Luna sell and Skarsgard
Genevieve O'Reilly and created by Tony
Gilroy critics say a gritty Adventure
told from the ground perspective of the
Empire's Reign Andor is an exceptionally
mature and political entry into the Star
Wars Mythos and one of the best yet
foreign
look at the window
I don't have the speed to make it and
now you want me to climb flying
foreign
[Music]
Number Five Star Wars the Clone Wars
the first weekly TV series from
lucasfilm animation Chronicles The
Adventures of Anakin Skywalker Yoda
Obi-Wan Kenobi and other popular
characters from the Star Wars Universe
during the violent Clone Wars as
dwindling numbers of Jedi Knights
struggle to restore peace starring Matt
Lanter Ashley Eckstein Tom Kane and
James Arnold Taylor critics say with an
agreeably entertaining first season Star
Wars the Clone Wars opens a fun
kid-friendly chapter of the franchise's
sprawling mythology
I have come to surrender
surrender that's a relief notify that
the technical Droid
forces fought valiantly and I must admit
that we are overmatched by your Superior
Firepower I congratulate
how much longer we stuck down here
I'll tell the boys all right man hang in
there a little longer
yes uh so it is with these thoughts in
mind that I gladly surrender myself to
the uh
see of these separatist forces why have
you cease fire
it's a trap you fools open fire now or
two
because
[Music]
thank you
number four the Mandalorian after the
fall of the Galactic Empire a lone
gunfighter makes his way through the
outer reaches of the Lawless Galaxy
starring Pedro Pascal Carl Weathers
Giancarlo Esposito and created by John
Favreau critics say action-packed and
expertly crafted if at times a bit too
withholding the Mandalorian is a welcome
addition to the Star Wars universe that
benefits greatly from the cuteness of
its cargo
grief karga said you were coming
what else did he say
he said you were the best in the parsec
three no drop your weapons
no no no pardon uh sorry I didn't mean
to alarm
stop the person
please excuse his lack of decorum
his enthusiasm outweighs his discretion
please lower your blaster two of them
lower theirs first we have you four to
one
I like those odds Number Three Star Wars
visions
seven Japanese animation Studios bring
their unique perspectives to the Star
Wars Universe through a series of short
films starring Joseph Gordon-Levitt
kamiko Glenn Karen fukuhara and Jamie
Chung critics say gorgeously animated
and wildly Creative Visions is an
Eclectic but wholly enjoyable collection
of Star Wars stories that breathe new
life into the Galaxy
[Music]
what's this
it's me you can't even save yourself
all right
number two Star Wars Rebels
this animated entry in the Star Wars
franchise fills a gap between the events
of episode 3 and episode 4. Imperial
forces occupy a remote planet and are
ruling and ruining its inhabitants lives
with an iron fist a clever disparate
crew aboard the Starship ghost takes the
sand against the empire facing new
villains and colorful adversaries the
Rebels on the ghosts include leader
Kanan Ace pilot Hera feisty heroine
Sabine tough guy Zeb and 14 year old con
artist Ezra starring David oyelo Vanessa
Marshall Taya sir Carr and created by
Dave filoni Simon kinberg and Carrie
Beck critics say Rebels adds new
dimension to an unexplored sector of the
Star Wars timeline inserting a ragtag
group of lovable characters into a
galactic Adventure that all ages can
enjoy
Chopper
[Music]
so we have them pinned
don't have all day we have to get back
[Music]
foreign
well then my Brave young boy come and
prove it
[Music]
and finally number one Star Wars tales
of the Jedi
this brand new animated shorts featuring
Parables built around Jedi from the
prequel era journey into the lives of
two distinctly different Jedi Ahsoka
Tano and Count Dooku each will be put to
the test as they make choices that will
Define their Destinies starring Ashley
Eckstein Corey Burton Liam Neeson and
created by Dave filoni and Charles
Murray critics say under the reliable
stewardship of Dave filoni tales of the
Jedi is an absorbing expansion of Star
Wars lore that will Delight Padawan
level fans and encyclopedic force
Scholars alike
claim Jedi was here and yet I find no
one I promise you they'll be back you
you favor he's not lying
let them go see I told you they'd be
back
so you did
here is your reward
can it be
[Music]
you're supposed to be dead
dancing
foreign
[Music]
that about does it for us be sure to
stay tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes
channel for more of the entertainment
content you love until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]